this retreat is one of the sexiest
people in the world I will read myself a
10 out of 10 bring that here really did
this is literally heaven on earth all
falling in love with someone behind a
wall was crazy
Netflix's newest reality series too hot
to handle has up the ante I'm Nana
there are conditions to your stay here
no kissing or sex or any kind of [ __ ] as
if some robot is telling me I can't do
anything it's not easy to go an extended
period of time without any sexual
release this retreat is to help you gain
deeper emotional connections it's blue
balls a real thing
we'll find out we're calling it now this
is your next quarantine binge obsession
and the entire first season drops Friday
April 17th ET spoke exclusively with
some of the cast to see exactly what we
can expect from the no sex dating series
I thought that it was gonna be just like
a dating show you get to go there
there's like spit guys hot girls you get
different challenges together and and
when I when I heard you're not allowed
when Lana told us to be honest a part of
me was like glad because I don't my nan
or my mom to like see me do rumpy-pumpy
on the TV so it was very exciting it was
a bit of a bummer at the same time so
did the cast know what they were getting
into when they signed up here's a 26
year old model francesca tells ET when
you auditioned and you were going
through everything what kind of
questions were you being asked and what
did it make you think the show was gonna
be I honestly had no idea it could have
been a show like survivor it could have
been like The Bachelorette it could have
been like love is blind like I actually
was just open to the idea of going on it
I knew I had to be single that was one
of their
and like sunshine so I was okay perfect
perfect I'm old a and B I really didn't
know and kind of right before we left
for filming we found out that it was
called untitled dating show so then I
was like perfect this is great like
overall the experience was so amazing
and it was probably like the wildest
entire life
Chloe also revealed how excited she is
for the world to see the show after
keeping it a secret for about a year
how does it feel for you knowing that
everybody's about to see what you guys
filmed how do you think they'll react to
be honest I'm just full of excitement
right now like my adrenaline is just
this amazing experience and what we went
through emotionally to kind of like
connect with ourselves and to connect
with other people on such a deep
emotional level it's just I cannot wait
for people to just watch what we we've
done on the show is so exciting cast
member Sharon Townsend gave us some
insight on how Lana the robot could find
out if they broke any rules
how could Lana or the cameras really
know if you didn't even self-pleasure
like what about the shower Lana has eyes
so Lana can be seen fitted into the
shower where Lana can see everything and
Sharon also revealed which cast member
he thinks will become a fan favorite for
the most part I think everyone's gonna
be lovable I know he was gonna love
Harry Harry was he had it quite a sense
of humor I'm definitely a great great
kid and like the naughty little possum
like cool I mean that that was amazing
like so he definitely impressed me while
I was there so I know to Castle loved
him um Chloe also like Chloe had a she's
like the little sister so you had like
yeah there's been a lot more time with
Khloe but Khloe I think for the most
part everyone gonna be loved I don't
think this was the show where like
they're gonna be anyone when it comes
out not like favorite it speaking of
Chloe she has a message for viewers she
wanted to share before binging starts
this weekend isn't just to show it's um
that
we actually experience this in the villa
their real emotions real tears I cried
handful of times
I'm such an emotional person and to go
through falling in love to falling out
with someone to having drama for
everyone to come together or under
cameras is just it's for non phenomenal
[Music]